Every day, the human race produces about 70 billion fart - it means almost
10 of these decrees were issued from you! But why do not the gases from you look so bad?
Why do we feel the smell of our feet?
As it seems funny, scientists have proved this information. In tests of blind smell,
We really smell the aroma of our fart more than others. Simply,
Whenever something is familiar to you, as you associate with a song, a picture or even an odor,
The more likely you prefer it. And because the bacteria that live in your body are released
These odors are unique and vary according to individuals. Our fart is really a unique sign
Our enemies can separate them.
But from an evolutionary perspective, we reacted to the imperatives of others
Is probably the way our brain protects us from causing harm to our bodies ... precisely
Dealing with disease sources. When you think about it, most things are
Do not like her smell, not good for you. The higher the risk of disease, the stronger our reaction
Towards the smell.
It is as surprising as it seems, the ram is spreading diseases. In fact, there are several reports states that
Dirt helps in the diffusion of nodal lump, a pathogen that causes inflammation of the tonsils, scarlet fever,
Heart disease and even diseases that eat the skin. Realistically, this nurse comes out
Stools or particles of stool in the air. Of course, this was a troubling reason
Our ancestors who were running naked. But for us, who wear underwear, do not dart
Causing real damage.
It is important to us that we adapt ourselves to our smells so that we can take care of ourselves
Clean up. In the same way, mothers see that their children's feces are less
So that they can take care of their children without disgust.
Some of you are probably thinking: "I do not dislike the dart at all" - and
you are not alone. To depict the disgusting mixture of variables such as age, sex,
Culture and even personality. Socially anxious and socially motivated individuals
More sensitive than the pungent smells of their adventure-loving colleagues.
The front fascial cortex, responsible for the snap process, also has a significant role. When we bend
We know that and expect the accompanying odor. A tune when someone whispers a silent fart
With a deadly smell in a room full of imaginations, the minds of the truth shatter because of
The negative stimulus, causing all this to seem more hateful. So, next time you will be hurt by a silent fart,
Tell everyone in advance. Unless you are
Lonely; to enjoy your hurdles alone.
Do not forget, our book will be available for purchase soon! It is not only possible to obtain your copy
Of your favorite episodes, which we have redrawn and renewed, we too
We have written some new chapters that answer your questions that we can not answer here
On AsapSCIENCE! Take a look here asapscience.com/book for your copy! We are really grateful
Your continuous support!
You can also watch the latest AsapTHOUGHT episode entitled "Flag of the beard" wherever
We discuss the benefits of raising or shaving the beard completely. To raise beards
or not? They went there with the help of the link in the details, and told us which
This is the winner!
And subscribe to our channel for more science seminars per week!